Randy "Macho Man" Savage, a professional wrestler known for his raspy voice, sunglasses and bandanas,...
...has died in a car crash in Florida.
He was 58. The Florida highway patrol says Savage was driving a Jeep Wrangler when he lost control,...
...going over a concrete median barrier and then crashed into a tree in Pinellas County.
Police say he may have suffered what they called a "medical event" before the accident.
An autopsy will determine the cause of death for sure.
Savage helped define the larger than life personalities, the 1980s of the World Wrestling Federation,...
...now the WWE, helping build it into a mainstream phenomenon.
Oh yeah! Oh yeah! Dig it!
Savage had not appeared for a major wrestling outlet since 2004.
Lee Powell, The Associated Press.